delivery that line wasn't in the movie
but there was a bullet that totally
melted the guy's head so I mean that was
cool dread-nots Judge Dredd not just
Dredd one-word name what a drama queen
so Dredd is a reboot of the Judge Dredd
story enough for the reboot they got
Karl Urban being Judge Dredd I loved
Karl Urban is Judge Dredd one of the
coolest things in this movie is that
they never show him with his helmet off
like he's a symbol not a person I like
that and the story in this movie is that
the USA in probably the world but
definitely USA is a thermal nuclear
wasteland and there's a big-ass city
they do a really good job at
illustrating this city sucks ass no one
wants to live there but there's nowhere
else to live see it's huge - it expands
states and the men and women of the Hall
of Justice not that not that hollow
justice and yeah the judge dredd Hall of
Justice they're trying to maintain the
peace and these judges are judge jury
and executioner on scene so long story
short Judge Dredd training this rookie
chick is pretty hot and she's psychic
and I was like save what come on psychic
I didn't have high hopes for this movie
now we have a psychic on the scene
however I gave the movie a shot so Judge
Dredd and this chick judge in training
he's a psychic go into this big building
is a big-ass tall building that's pretty
much like if I can compare it to
anything it's like Omega from Mass
Effect - no that's where all the crime
and the shitty scumbags hang out and do
their dealings there's a lot of murder
there do you have civilians that live in
the mix but they don't really matter
I lived there not because they want to
just kind of because that's where they
live so they go in there to get someone
Lena Headey who runs the entire thing
locks the place down she's like hey any
scumbags out there kill the street
judges and now we have our action movie
because the bullets start flying and I'm
not gonna lie to you I thought this
movie was going to be dreadful I had no
hope for this movie but the movie is
pretty fun first of all I thought I'd
seen everything there was to offer with
slow-mo usually I'm like way too many
slow-mo shots in this movie what's the
point of the slow-mo what's the deal
with all the slow-mo
but they had a story-based reason for
the Slovo in this movie there's this
drug people inhale it it makes the mind
think that times passing it like 1% it's
normal rate so everyone's all like
tripping balls doing this [ __ ]
everything is all just like really slow
motion what's really cool is when you
see tweakers on that and Judge Dredd
kicks the door in and you see what he
sees he's just wasting people in the
bull
let's start cutting through people's
faces in slo-mo and you're just like
alright new application for slo-mo it's
not a new application I guess it's just
the same thing it's slo-mo bullets
flying through the air and shredding
through people but you respect it more
for being worked into the story you're
like alright props this movie had some
badassery bullets are flying it's
violent as hell yeah they'll leave the
kids at home it's not for them is it
entertaining for we adults yeah it is
another thing this movie has is a great
villain Lena Headey usually she's hot as
hell and this one she looks like a
Tweaker scumbag Scarface piece of [ __ ]
and she plays arguably the biggest
Thunder [ __ ] you've ever seen on screen
and I know it's true though it's true
for people who are like he said that
word I did but it's true there's no
other word to describe her you can take
the nicest girl ever who's like I hate
the c-word she'll come out of this movie
being like yeah that chick was one
comeback piece of [ __ ] she needed to go
down bring in the dread Lena Headey did
a great job at playing a great villain
this chick was just evil and what I
liked among all the action that's really
awesome i candy and you're just having
popcorn fun with it it's the fact that
the street judges have their code the
chick in this movie she's psychic and
she reads two's mind she's like I'm 99%
sure that that guy has murdered a lot of
people Judge Dredd the best Batman voice
ever so like 99% ain't enough I was like
holy [ __ ] that dude needs a hundred
percent now guys a legit street judge
and the whole psychic thing as cheesy as
that could've been was actually used
really well in the movies as well as
throwing a psychic in the mix could be
for a couple of really cool moments
where they used it there were even a
couple of moments in this movie where I
was like I didn't expect that couple of
cool character moments where you're like
hey thanks popcorn movie for being just
a little more than you had to be but in
the end the thing I love about this
movie is it knows what it is it doesn't
try to have some big conspiracy with
chief justice's there's no shitty clone
aspect it's like hey let's do Judge
Dredd with as much bullets as you can
put on the screen let's just have people
have fun this is pretty much popcorn
movie the way popcorn movies should be
in the end I will say I will buy Dredd
on blu-ray there's a fun ass movie with
an evil villain and a badass judge so
what's your favorite action movie of the
year not counting the Avengers stop it
no cheating whatever your favorite
action movie of the year is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more